[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france l'exécutif dit tout
et son contraire
oui alors c'est vrai qu'on a entendu
beaucoup de choses ces derniers jours à
la fois monsieur vaccin monsieur fisher
qui était rassurant en disant que ce
rythme lent été voulue c'était pour
assurer les français et puis on apprend
dans le jdd quesnel macron était dans
une colère noire que ça n'allait pas
assez vite
jean castex le premier ministre quant à
lui il disait simplement que ce n'est
pas du retard c'est simplement du
décalage et que le gouvernement français
suit un chemin le chemin de la
vaccination
on espère que ce sera pas l'équivalent
du chemin des dames en 14-18 parce que
là ce serait quand même à une hécatombe
si c'était le cas et puis si on regarde
les chiffres là on est en plein dans la
contradiction par rapport à ce qui a été
dit le discours de jean castex le 16
décembre à l'assemblée nationale pour
présenter cette fameuse stratégie
la livraison des doses d'ici la fin
décembre
la france devait recevoir un million
cent soixante mille doses puis 8 177
mille tonnes supplémentaires autour du 5
et du 6 janvier et enfin 1 million 600
mille doses supplémentaires en février
or qu'est ce qu'a dit olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé à l'hôtel-dieu
lundi nous avons reçu cinq cent mille
doses et nous en attendons 580 1000
d'ici mercredi donc on est loin du
compte et on se demande où sont passés
les doses est ce qu'il ya eu trop
d'effets d'annoncé ce que cette campagne
finalement elle a été d'abord mis sur la
communication avant d'être mis sur la
logistique et la vaccination alors face
aux critiques le gouvernement promet
d'accélérer et de simplifier est-ce que
cela se concrétise alors accéléré c'est
ce qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui par
l'irrévérence 7000 vaccination mais on
est loin du compte bien entendu
seulement eu 27 hôpitaux une trentaine
d'hôpitaux qui ont été livrées ça fait
peu sur le nombre d'hôpitaux pour
pouvoir se faire vacciner
en revanche pour la parole politique sur
les plateaux de télévision
alors là oui les ténors de la majorité
sont accélérées une pas et on a pu voir
gabriel attal olivier ferrand jean
castex mails mâcon qu'a pris la parole
de manière détournée mais clairement la
gestion en bon père de famille a été mis
de côté
la stratégie de la tortue aussi
maintenant il faut aller vite et puis on
apprend aussi que c'est un cabinet de
conseil le cabinet mckinsey qui est en
charge de cette stratégie vaccinale
on sait déjà que c'était le cabinet bain
and company qui avait été chargé par
jean castex a l'époque monsieur
déconfinement du déconfinement à chaque
fois on a l'impression que ces gens qui
sont quand même payé par nos impôts à
faire beaucoup de choses et bien se
tourner vers le privé pour organiser les
choses à leur place et ils découvrent
finalement que au coeur de la stratégie
vaccinale plutôt que de mettre des
grands pontes de la médecine
il fallait des logisticiens des gens qui
étaient capables d'acheminer les doses
de vaccins d'un point a à un point b
avec ses super congélateur bien sûr
qu'ils sont la clé puisque les vaccins
doivent être gardés au frais à moins 80
degrés et puis et puis chez les
soignants et bien on commence à
s'inquiéter avec une tribune demandant
plus de clarté dans cette stratégie
vaccinale puisque encore une fois jean
castex avait promis de la transparence
or transparence il n'y en a pas ni sur
les honoraires de mckinsey ni sur le
nombre de doses qui sont sur le
territoire ni sur le rythme à laquelle
cette vaccination va se mettre en place
un raté la campagne de vaccination est
ce que cela pourrait signifier la fin
politique d' emmanuel macron où c'est
peut-être exagéré alors peut-être pas sa
fin politique puisque en politique rien
n'est jamais fini
sauf vraiment à la toute fin mais ça
pourrait sérieusement mettre en doute
une potentielle candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
parce que quel bilan aurait-il à
défendre sur cette gestion sanitaire il
ya eu la cacophonie et le fiasco des
masques et le fiasco des tests le fiasco
maintenant de du d
vaccination on va voir comment ça se
passe par la suite mais on a
l'impression que ces conseils de la
défense
ils ne servent à rien à part assuré le
secret défense
et au final le dire mais comment elle
gérait finalement la politique sanitaire
en france est aujourd'hui tout va se
tourner bien sûr vers cette politique
sanitaire et je crois que le quoi qu'il
en coûte
demel macron valent peut-être me coûter
cher parce que on est en train de fermer
des secteurs entiers de la société
secteur de la culture secteur de la nuit
de la restauration les bars c'est
beaucoup d' aide beaucoup d'entreprises
qui hélas est malheureusement vont faire
faillite
beaucoup de gens qui vont se retrouver
au chômage une croissance qui ne risque
pas d'être au rendez vous le quoi qu'il
en coûte risque d'être un tout ça pour
ça qui va coûter extrêmement cher à
emmanuel macron mais aussi à sa majorité
alors sans compter qu'un nouveau
scandale politique est en vue pour le
président on a appris aujourd'hui
l'ancien ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn entre au cabinet du directeur
général de l'ons ms ce sont ses
compétences qui sont reconnues alors si
ces compétences pourquoi pas agnès buzyn
c'est elle qui disait que tout allait
bien que ce virus n'était pas là encore
sur le territoire européen
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça qu'il organise
sa défense devant la commission d'
enquête parlementaire en disant que
finalement tout ce qu'elle a fait est
parfait puisqu'il n'y avait pas de virus
à l'époque où il était aux commandes
c'est elle qui a mis des affiches à
l'aéroport pour accueillir le virus en
provenance du monde entier
c'est elle qui n'a pas recommandé les
masques quand elle savait que ça
n'allait pas qu'ils savent être dès
décembre que quelque chose n'allait pas
qui parlait du fiasco de la mascarade
des élections municipales
la voilà récompensé on est dans ce qu'on
appelle une cas qui stockera si c'est à
dire que ce sont les plus médiocres qui
sont récompensés il s'agit là des xi
litres et agnès buzyn sans doute de lui
promettre un poste à l'étranger c'est ce
dont elle rêvait pour garder le silence
pour aussi être protégés sans doute des
journalistes français trop curieux qui
lui poserait beaucoup de questions sur
cette gestion de crise parce que ses
réponses devant la commission denquête
finalement on peu satisfait les députés
qui étaient devant elle donc voilà la
faillite morale finalement de ce
gouvernement qui refuse la
responsabilité qui va de pair avec les
devoirs de
deux des élus et des politiques il
s'agit de fuir on a eu lors de la crise
et du scandale du sang contaminé
responsable mais pas coupable
on a maintenant avec ce gouvernement ni
responsable ni coupable
courage fuyons la suite nous dira ce
qu'il en sera puisqu'il ya toujours de
nombreuses plaintes qui sont en cours
vis-à-vis de madame besoins mais
également de l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe et d'autres
responsables de ces fiascos à répétition
donc la suite au prochain numéro mais
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui si nous
sommes en guerre
une déroute qui nous est proposée par ce
gouvernement merci alexis poulain